well there's probably over 200 million
vaccines that are stored in america
europe britain and canada that you could
airlift out tomorrow and you could start
to solve the problem of only two percent
vaccinated in low-income countries only
five percent in africa you know the good
news is the vaccines are there the bad
news is they're not properly distributed
and the world health organization is now
saying that if we don't vaccinate people
we could have five million more deaths
next year and 200 million more cases and
that's really suggesting that we're only
halfway through this pandemic unless we
take the action to vaccinate
where does this leave us in terms of the
contracts i mean are we in terms of the
pre-ordering i mean are we blocking up
that supply chain as well
yeah what's happened is that the
countries that got in at the beginning
over-ordered and they're now being
over-supplied so we're in danger of
wasting
tens of millions of vaccines that are
going to pass their expiry date and
can't get out to the people that need
them and yet we know that nobody is safe
around the world until everybody is
vaccinated and we need to get these
vaccines out to prevent the disease
mutating and coming back to hit us even
the fully vaccinated here just like the
delta variant came out of india we could
have variants coming out of africa latin
america and asia and so it's in all our
interest to vaccinate people as quickly
as possible and particularly when we
have these excess supplies and that's
after all the boosters and after the
teenagers being vaccinated we've still
got this excess amount of supply we
should get that out as quickly as
possible to people whose lives could be
saved i mean the way you phrase it makes
seems like common sense they are an
urgent urgent need in other parts of the
world and if we've got all of our bases
covered here why isn't more action
happening now
it's a lack of coordination people are
not getting their act together it's a
bit like cop 26 in glasgow we're not
getting agreements because people are
not coming around the table and deciding
to do things together what you need is a
timetable a delivery plan you need the
richest nations with the vaccines coming
together so that they can get the
vaccines out to the poorest nations the
g20 is meeting this weekend so they're
the countries that have got the vaccines
they should be agreeing to have a task
force to get the vaccines out airlift
them use the militaries start to save
lives instead of seeing lives being lost
how confident are you that that could
happen
i think that countries are starting to
realize that it's not enough to say
we're going to give donations next year
or a few this year and a bit more next
year we've got to have a month by month
plan and i'm
hoping that the g20 tomorrow under the
italian chairmanship will agree that
they're going to get this timetable in
place and get the delivery plan and i
keep saying to people it's in
everybody's interest that this happens
because if people are not vaccinated in
africa it means the disease will spread
from there we've got to stop it in our
own interests
in terms of the global vaccination rates
i mean they're still looking pretty poor
by the end of this year 12 months on
from the start of the vaccination
program aren't they
well it's 70 vaccination in the west two
percent in low-income countries five
percent in africa you know only one in
every 10 health workers in africa have
been vaccinated so 90 percent are not
yet vaccinated
and they're risking their lives to save
lives and we haven't managed to get the
vaccines to them we really have to move
quickly and urgently because today i
think we'll pass the figure for five
million deaths as a result of covert and
it would be criminal really if another
five million deaths have to happen
because we haven't got vaccines that we
have to the people who need them
and i think everybody in this country
will say look if we've got the boosters
and we've got children vaccinated we
should get the rest of these vaccines
that are left over out to the people who
need them
golden brown good to talk to you thank
you